you can call me just just call me just
call me by my name it's a
um another name Hurst last name is Hurst
um
um Angelica Hurst and Angelic and
Angelica Hearst sure
Angelique where'd you grow up where are
you from
um well my life as actually it's a funny
question you asked me my life has been
it's all pre-production for my life
so how am I gonna do how am I gonna
answer the questions
because we haven't started we haven't
started the original for the final
original for everyone and everything
um because we're not going to go in a
circle this time we're gonna go forward
to the future
um
what you drinking
thank you
I'm so thirsty
um what are you drinking
uh Arnold Palmer um
um
you can call me Alexia too Capital
Alexia and that's my name I just shared
it with a I mean I was I was doing these
codes
and I put everybody's name in Alexia so
people started calling themselves Alexia
Lexi tell me about your childhood your
family growing up um
I just don't offend anybody
um so misunderstood
um my childhood
this my childhood was really rough
um because I had to be uh
I had an uh we didn't know it was wrong
you know in America we don't know that
abortion I mean we're really young if
you have a clinic somewhere like I just
assumed the clinic or the hospital was
like a normal place you know you go to
get better
so I was really naive
and we're really we're all really young
you know on a 12-month calendar
and so I had an abortion
um and uh I don't know what I was
thinking I guess they promoted it on
television like it's so normal
um I was uh 15.
um
and of course I would never
I would never you know since then I've
been doing like
this is a long time ago this is like my
pre-prem because I'm back again it's
complicated to explain but this is my
when I when I was like I'm I keep the
same um
I'm very old actually spiritually and
physically
I just don't don't betray it I don't
look like it you don't no that's why I'm
not used to uh
I'm not really used to
um doing interviews or asking people
asking questions because they're like
what
um but yeah it was a long time ago when
I when this happened it was like my
final time as being of being in my old
life I was elected dubasso girl that
went to school I went to Lisa for a
little while it was a French school
um and that was a great upbringing I had
a beautiful childhood it was like the
best ever but I had to do a lot of work
because of the abortion I had to do a
lot of amends it's very heavily heavy
penalty to get into a Heavenly Place
very heavy so um I dedicated my life to
like working with children and I have
ever since
um and Mike and you know for for the
children so uh yeah I love I love
children I love children's childhood is
the most important so I got really
really into saving little little babies
really small babies there's not a lot of
children here on Skid Row
are those a little older I deal with the
baby baby babies and like newborns and
even before newborn because God has you
uh when you have an abortion if he
really like loves you and you have a
good connection with him and your fate
and you love God thank God I did
um he had me I had to go through feeling
with the abortion pains felt like being
aborted I had to get aborted
and um
um it was like the worst day of my life
um or the worst three days
um I heard that my uh I I didn't I don't
know you're so young you know
um like not even uh and we're still
naive
when I just feel terrible sometimes
people look at like that that's a
monstrous thing to do
and it really it just really wasn't
um it's misunderstood
or lack of experience
how would you describe your childhood in
general
um my childhood well it was um I was a
child having a child
um I've said like big universe myself so
going through that I had to carry myself
and then you get reborn to my reborn
names day uh
was on uh three
my original birthday 219 1988.
uh perfect past history
um before having Megan as a cover
um because she's a fantastic fantastic
person
um I mean Jennifer
um
and uh
and now uh I uh I guess Alexia from the
15 month calendar so I wasn't aware of
what was going on like I don't know what
this colors mean or what that means
because I'm I'm really no one tells me
anything I have to learn myself
so I gave birth to myself
and um
um but um
she didn't come out of me she just kind
of like I had to
uh how do you explain it that's really
weird so I was really abused
you know I was really abused
um people didn't want to um they thought
I was a drug addict
and um
I uh when drug addiction happens there's
no such thing as drug addiction drug
addiction happens when the person is not
needs more and more they don't have the
right medicine they're just not getting
the right medicine
uh they need more of it because they
need a stronger dose they need something
more
um if you get the right medicine or if
you get the right pill and uh you won't
need to have it all the time it'll come
really naturally like or the white or
the right alcohol alcohol too is really
misunderstood
so um and Spirits are important
so we need to keep in touch with our
family
um Jesus drank one you know he was very
very he was very obvious about it when
he sat at the table and was like you're
out of a glass of wine I'm sitting with
my friends come break bread with me and
my you know my darlings to my or was she
to the right of the left
it's very similar to me in my
relationship with my son
because you know Jesus is Mom
was his mother Mary it was his wife Mary
no and I guess eventually later on maybe
his daughter even
I really love Mary
what kind of girl were you in high
school Alexia
excuse me what kind of girl were you in
high school
oh
um
since I wasn't adopted and I still I
called myself Daniel Lindberg Lindbergh
it was Danielle lindenberg
and then I changed it to El birdie and I
had a really strange childhood because I
didn't really have my parents I guess
were still associated with my
previous uh you know stature and so
being born on 318 2020 or born again I
guess that's what you're what God means
when you're born again
but normal people would be born again
and have an Enlightenment this wasn't a
enlightening experience but it really
was enlightening because
um abortion is now illegal in um
how many states
I mean the whole world it would be
illegal and and you know very soon
everywhere
because uh the baby's very conscious
and I had to experience uh three uh
minutes of the uh pain
and I had Angels or the baby I didn't
know later I had so many fans I was so
lucky but I didn't know you most
experienced three days
of that pain
God is very gracious but and the people
are so gracious but um I felt really bad
about it like I haven't really forgiven
myself for about it
like I I didn't um we're just uh
yeah so I had a really rough childhood
I felt like I'd been cut off from the
Creator
because that's what happens when you get
an abortion
are drugs a part of your life
um yeah I thought drugs were like uh
normal
because um
the food uh
I didn't I I
mean drugs if they're if they're part of
that yeah they're normal drugs are drugs
are um like I said they're very personal
heroin came out and it was specifically
for the same girls that were doing
martership work
so it was called heroin and it also was
about soulmate uh relationships with the
straight people with a straight person
to a woman and a man because they
believe that women come from Venus and
Men come from Mars so they thought if
they both had a drug
heroin would be good for the girl and
hero would be good for the guy so when
they would be apart from each other and
a hero could keep his men and then the
heroine could keep her heroine but
together
they can make it work
and hero never came out heroin came out
and was stolen
um by the public because it was I heard
it was a private drug
actually the same thing but there's
different kinds of heroin
um and uh Hiro was supposed to come out
and
um it didn't which also says a lot
speaks a lot
about not accepting our alpha male in
society
and um
giving him away as so therefore we never
even get the Omega factor in because
people were murdering their their their
own people and their lineage to their
creator
by getting abortions and things like
that which is such a dangerous thing to
do to society
how old are you Alexia
um well I I was born in 88
um but on a planet uh called a Sirius
xmu
it was like my home it was my Earth
I didn't know there was any other planet
I thought that was Earth
and it's much smaller it's very small
planet it's very intimate and people are
really nice we don't have any um
problems it might even been planned in
Hollywood some people called it
um Planet Hollywood
um
was my poem it wasn't just a movie place
to do movies and it was like my home I
loved it
I'm so homesick I never got
the siriusxmu never found me again I
heard them make an announcements you
know but I was I had such a terrible
um
so hard to be so young
because I'm missing the um
the calls no one would tell me anything
they wouldn't say anything they were
quiet
have you ever been treated for
mental conditions
I heard that uh yeah I heard that the
medication should be the letters of your
name
because you carry Karma with your name
and the letter somehow corresponded I
don't know how that works but
but um
yeah
have you taken medications yeah I liked
Lexapro a lot I loved it
it was great the drugs really work now
and they're healthy for you but if you
take a drug that's not good for you
um it can be so the consequences are
irreversible you could be drifting apart
from all your friends which I believe is
the reason why I'm missing my friends is
because so many stops got me sober and I
started syncing they kind of forced me
to get sober at the wrong time and it
was a really strange situation it was
even not even me or my family it was
like an outside source and they had some
sort of control over me
and they just didn't want me to get high
but I wasn't really getting that high I
was just coping with life and I didn't
have the right medicine
because fentanyl really changed my life
um there's many brands of fentanyl the
purple one is my kind and it goes for
the JC crew people who are uh we call
the JC crew club and purple uh fentanyl
is really good for us because of her
Aura you match the color there's
actually a color coding table you follow
to know the right medicine
and it really works
um yeah but I couldn't get the purple
one I do the white one
they also have red
oh you've been on the streets
um I'm not like really really on the
streets but I'm definitely on the
streets at the same time because I was
kind of shut out to close the door on me
they wouldn't let me in or they wouldn't
let the they thought I was someone else
and they just refused to open the doors
and they all took off and closed it
behind me so I've been very lonely very
sad
I felt very used
what do you do for money
um
well
they put money in my card but people
just usually pull it out they got access
to my EBT card I don't know how they do
it but they do it
then they block my parents numbers
and they um
they took all my contacts away I can't
even reached my mother
I can't reach my father
um if you can if you ever if you can
find them like if somebody knows where I
am because it even doesn't even look
like the same city I might be in the
portal house which is really real and
they just didn't know they thought it
was spiritual what city are your is your
family in
um where's my family sorry what city is
your family in Los Angeles California
that's where we are but we might be in
the spiritual world is really real
because somebody immortalized it as
realer than this physical
I don't know like so I think it
overlayered
and it's really complicated to find
people now it's almost really scary
because um there's a map of the universe
actually finds it
is the last time you spoke to your
family
I feel like I speak to them all the time
because I always hear them around me
I don't do really well
when
um
I don't do really well
when I'm alone sometimes
what do you go through emotionally
living this life
you get depressed you get anxious you
get angry do you get depressed
sorry
do you have any regrets in your life
well they're just contorting things
they're lying to the people I can't
really hear my mother they're just lying
to the people they put veils over your
eyes
so many I could look like anybody
they immortalized me as the devil but
you can change it right away I can look
like anybody
you know
you just have to do somebody has my my
soul mate my significant other is
supposed to have like access to my you
know he would know me right you think
he'd know me
but like where is he
um
that he would have access to my MK Ultra
codes
but he took off or something
so somebody else so some foreign country
has access to it and so they're always
messing with me
like I'm an 8 AI
official
I'm a 10 AI spiritually officially
so being like this I had to cut off
everything and I'm just extremely
unconsciously
unconscious and people keep on trying to
make me look bad
I don't know why
have you been in love before
um
see I hear horrible things like
someone's hitting my son where's my baby
and I hear crying like it's just like I
can't I can't live like this I want to
go home I have two I have two kids you
know you do yeah three actually three
and two
I had one I wasn't aware of really it's
a strange story too I think women have
babies all the time we're not aware of
how many children do you have
um I have a three I found out that I had
three a really big tummy
and it got really small
I love my babies I love all of them
um about Balthazar bazarus bizarre are
my three
uh British babies they live in England
um and we rarely speak but I used to
make their lunches for them in the
spiritual world for their food they
would call football soccer
in the field and they would have
knapsacks and you hang them in the tree
and I wanted to I wanted to be cool like
their other moms you know I tried you
know I tried like a few times they're a
lot bigger than me they're like Angelic
Birds carnarian lineage royalty and I'm
just like this little thing from like 12
months I'm not even like truly like you
know I'm like trying but I'm but I I do
have my spiritual clothes so hopefully I
don't want to look like you know strange
and don't embarrassing and embarrassed
and then I had a son Tristan
um
um Valentine's really really beautiful
boy and
I'm really proud of him I miss him
terribly all the time
um I like dedicate my life to make my
kids happy I steal their Futures they
got the perfect future they have a
perfect pass history like I really
worked on them
including a lot of my other spiritual
children but Leander
um
love Leander
and I'm really close to them Spirit
they're with me all the time
we go off together and we come back and
we're really like happy holy spirits so
we rarely come down like together all of
us together it's very rare
which is really sad
when's the last time you saw your kids
um I'm with them all the time like
so it's hard to say when I last saw them
physically played with them
it's been like two three
three years now
four years maybe
but I saw my child just because oh
because of this situation because I have
to make I can't be looking like a
monster in front of them like I don't
know someone I feel like someone who
plays playing with the camera work you
know my body but I have to be really
really really it's not that I can't be
on my children I just want them to have
like a normal life and I don't want
these strange people knowing where I
live
you know I don't even following me home
it scares me I feel like there's this
guy that like knows where I live and he
wants to like hurt my family or
something and it just makes me so
paranoid I don't dare go anywhere like I
don't dare to go home
like I'd rather not go home and know
where they are I know they're safe and
happy
where they are
I want to be with them so bad it kills
me
how long you been living like this
using drugs and all this
she's like we get pregnant really fast
like it's kind of funny like spiritually
too I guess like I just got a belly like
I'm not crazy like
it's really funny
um spiritual mothers do that one time
when do I what sorry when did you when
did the drug use start for you
um drug use started for me it's not
really focusing on drugs I'm not really
a drug addict like I said like it's
oxygen to me fentanyl means Heaven Sent
in Reverse I read the book right to left
first page because all the books are
written the wrong way
the government mistranslated everything
the sobriety is meant for a group of
boys called the Blue cops
and it's for the sobriety Blue Book and
it means um sobriety code it means
no it doesn't mean that that's an old
agenda it's in reversal not the opposite
perfect opposite if you use the opposite
new dictionary numerian written alphabet
English
uh Stanford standard new dictionary with
perfect words only
it's really important so people don't
misunderstand the words no one's
speaking badly about anybody or bad
viciously about anybody
um
they're not being a ugly thiased with
their words
what was your favorite memory from your
childhood
I'm sorry your favorite memory from your
um
so bright
so sensitive my eyes
uh pupils are like not a good thing
sometimes because they they let us it's
good thing to have now but I don't know
sometimes I can I can't see so well
it hurts
um sorry
what was your favorite memory from your
childhood
I don't know I still want to go back
home still a kid I want to be on earth
I'm really I'm really like seven years
old
um
if you remember on Earth I start
shrinking you know I'm messing stuff for
these are legible like the very but very
first one I had a private life though
like we're the 12 month Holy Spirit
small pool people no one ever see us you
know there's more than one layer here
like there's like uh up to like 14 I
heard I'm aware of seven
so it's not just like one or two or
three it's like a whole freaking no
there's more than seven because you have
the age groups that's per age group you
have like 20 of them 20 age groups hmm
what's your greatest strength
um
what do you mean in segment what's
happening what what are there any
personality traits that you have any
talents that you have that are that
you're particular University who has
military like where are you like I've
been screaming like subconsciously I'm
feeding after their help three days is
the most longest you can imprison
someone I'm just like I don't even know
like everyone just disappeared
I'm like what like where did everyone go
I'm like with the originals I'm an
original and I'm like what's going on
I just have to deal with it
so upsetting to like all your friends
are not there
I was like I'm so happy to be back like
I'm gonna can't wait to see everybody
and then like they're just like gone
like and then I'm like in a different
place I don't I still don't know where I
am like why does it look like LA and
it's not
um I hope they included this dimension
yeah
yeah your greatest fear
um
greatest fear
my greatest fear is to be alone like
and not have any uh companionships that
know
me know me like oh I know this I know
what you need I know what you want I'll
be there for you someone to trust
someone to take your hand and hold your
hand or like be with you just not I just
want to be alone and right now I feel
extremely isolated I need to have
friends that are my age you know and my
type
like I can't just be trapped with
animals
um
um by myself
I mean I could but
that'd be really hard
[Music]
what was your worst experience in your
life it's been the roughest part
someone's like says go to sleep like
they're trying to make me look like a
drug addict like this is always like
what are you doing
why do they do that
they're just manipulating everything
like who has my MCO Ultra like remote
Prince of what
he must hate and hate me hate vicious is
me
why can't I have my own control I
deserve it I got I want my original
custody over myself like I run my excuse
me
I won my own you know I worked just as
hard as the hardest working man in
Israel and uh three more days in him so
I Really Deserve
my pay their people are stealing
everything I mean they don't give me a
thousand dollars they make me any money
like it's really hard
um and they don't like me like why would
they want to purchase my rights to my
life and my body when they're just kind
of making fun of it like fun with it I
take my life very seriously
I'm really um
concerned about my future
not being exactly what I wanted it to be
or dreamed of it to be
and I guess that's normal
[Music]
just wish that I had someone that would
love me and care for me would have more
control over me you know but I don't
need someone to have control over me
I can handle myself I don't have like a
husband that's gonna like do that
like I have my kids
uh future kids but I'm so homesick like
I need to be in my Planetarium
I cannot live like in a planetarium it's
not for me it hurts so much to breathe
to walk everything it's just like it
doesn't it's not natural
did you have dreams of doing something
with your life sorry did you have goals
and dreams of
something you'd like to do with your
life oh yeah of course God I feel like I
feel like we've lost heaven like and I
can't seem to see it like I was so
perfect before
you don't even know like how perfect
everything was
and then for this infiltration to have
happened you know in the subconscious
World it just killed everything
and I don't know how to get it back I'm
trying so hard to feel it and to like
find it and I just
I can't
oh so they're just playing with me then
I can never be seen
who has it
can we buy the rights back from the
government of Persia because it's so
impossible they didn't let me do
anything they let me feel bad they're
killing my my whole thing
I mean they're just still gonna all the
things they've done pull it up all the
destructive patterns they've done to me
no
it's the 219 1988 UCLA
and then my born-again birthday
spiritually and physically because he
immortalizes more real
was uh 318-2020
I need a bed initiation I'm not like a
baby I need to sleep for like eight
months straight
I'm a vampire so
vampire like lamb p-i-r-e
it's a vampire
a baby uh
like uh
it's like a like a I don't know I'm
still homesick oh my gosh
I miss my agreement Cordell place I
would do anything to go back to my
Planet like I need to go onto my planet
I need to go home
I'm so homesick I can't even handle it I
don't know how to get home I feel like
all my friends are leaving me on the
stage and not helping me get out
I'm going to go over to Scott's I love
my boyfriend
he's like great
I feel like he doesn't love me as much
back recently I don't know why he's been
really strange and isolated
um
I just hope he's okay
yeah
I started seeing Sparkles like I don't
know sometimes I'm in different
dimensions
I mean you don't pull someone out of
their trip when they're in pneumonia
pneumonia is a place to get high and
that's why we have it it's to get high
and you can have fun there it's where
everyone's getting high
it's not meant to be like a normal place
oh no here we go again the Diamond Bar I
see I just think we're back in life and
then I realize oh no I must be like not
in heaven on Earth I'm not in the small
pool I'll try and replicate it as best
as I can
and I can't it's just not I feel like
I'm in hell
foreign
okay so I was just asking a question I'm
telepathic so sometimes well not really
I just hear I'm the inner holy spirit so
I can hear
oh so the real world oh I wouldn't show
this to the real world
um
um I wouldn't have done that at all
not at all like that's that's the I keep
three planetariums like really really
you know perfect like my sister she is a
perfect everything like she's so perfect
she deserves it like she has no memories
of anything horrible happening to her
like she's perfect like her baggage is
good she has a perfect future I put her
in a planetarium like away from
everybody because it was so bad and um
she didn't deserve to have that anymore
and she's she's she's so good like so I
can relax but after I finish saving
everyone and they're also they're all
set up I'm like I'm like oh like what do
I do so I can relax you know knowing
that they're all having a great future
and they're perfect but like
I'm lonely
yeah yeah
sorry
yeah I know it's so scary I'm so
frightened why
there we go ahead Mama I'm so scared I
want to be with my family
how do I reach you
yeah I'm going to see Scott right now
okay I'll be there in like 10 minutes
where are you
okay don't go anywhere because I want to
see you at the RV I'm so lonely like I
have to hold on to like my friends and
like I said um
um